il ya du progrès le monde a progressé
l'absence de guerre ça ne veut pas dire
la paix il arrive
certains l'appellent apocalypse c'est
une sorte de divinité depuis des
dizaines de millénaires il réunit des
mutants et s'approprient leur pouvoir il
était toujours suivie de quatre
disciples
comme les quatre cavalières eric ne
rejoint pas quoi que tu ai cru voir en
moi je les enterrer avec ma famille
ensemble nous purifieront la terre d'où
ce qu'ils ont construit ces fonds droit
sur les cendres de leur monde nous
envoyons je n'avais jamais ressenti un
tel pouvoir
ils ont enlevé raven le monde a besoin
des x men je suis pas une héroïne tu es
un modèle pour eux si je dois leur
apprendre quoi que ce soit je vais leur
apprendre à se battre
six mois
c'est toi j'ai pas peur de lui magnéto
c'est mon père quoi lui et ma mère un
moment et on rit
on ne peut pas tous contrôler nos
pouvoirs alors lâchez-vous
wasquehal ips entend détruire notre
monde
ça va être nous tous contre un dieu
et les créatures les plus puissantes de
la terre
oubliez tout ce que vous croyez savoir
tout ça appartient au passé
vous n'êtes plus à l'école
nous la reprendrons tout ce qu'il semble
vous êtes des x men
vous n'avez pas chômé on a eu un en
commun
ça promet
ça court
ce forum se joigne aux lèvres les yeux
thank you soon mais nous faut
beaucoup
what
non parce qu'une chose à part tel camp
après que le team c'est de sauver des
sports
bernard
une heure
aubin
m
hélas